today we are discussing one of the most
hype and Powerful groups in the world of
One Piece the Admirals all known ones in
history and their powers explained so
make sure to stay tuned for this one a
lot of new information has been revealed
about the group since the last Admirals
video including Luffy versus kizaru
including way more information about
greenbull including Kuan versus GARP and
much more so get hyped if you enjoy
seeing one piece videos like this one
and want to keep them coming chill
parking within and smash that like
button always be a smashing pck King
rather than a passing government Elder
make this the video you joined the Nako
by subscribing and hitting that
notification Bell so you don't miss
future one piece videos and updates we
are not far now from my insane dream of
2 million subscribers here on YouTube so
I would be eternally grateful if you
help us reach that goal with a push of
one virtual button now without further
Ado let's jump into It spoilers and all
so briefly the rank of Admiral is the
second highest rank in the Marines there
are only three Admirals at a time above
them is the fleet Admiral the highest
Marine rank although the fleet Admiral
commands the entire organization he is
still ranked below the world government
commander-in-chief the five elders and
the Mysterious IMU Sama the Admirals are
known as the world government's greatest
military power since each of them is
ridiculously strong Admirals including
of course the fleet Admiral can issue
Buster calls on islands that are deemed
to be threats let's start off with the
55-year-old red dog sakazuki who is over
10 ft tall by the way he used to be an
admiral and at that time he went by the
Alias Akainu or Akainu if you prefer
which literally translates to red AKA
and dog enu however now that he's Fleet
Admiral he goes by sakazuki when former
Fleet Admiral soku stepped down he
wanted aliji AKA Kon to take the job but
dignitaries within the world government
pushed for sakazuki so the two fought a
oneon-one duel the winner would seize
the right to command the Marines they
were evenly matched for 10 whole days
before sakazuki emerged Victorious also
taking kuan's Leg in the process aokiji
then left the Marines apparently not
wanting to work for sakazuki Sak
sakazuki was the most ruthless of all
the Admirals which is probably why
sangoku favored aliji sakazuki is
thorough in trying to stamp out whatever
or whoever he deems to be evil or a
threat to Absolute Justice as a result
he killed Ace and badly scarred Luffy
the new Fleet Admiral is the kind of guy
that would rather sacrifice innocent
lives than let one guilty person get
away which was shown when he destroyed a
refugee ship because one rule breaking
scholar might have made it on board in
contrast Kuan said he would never go as
far as that and called sakazuki a jerk
the current Fleet Admiral was even
willing to kill Kobe a marine just
because he wanted the battle at Marine
forward to end sakazuki is definitely an
ends justify the means kind of guy and
he will do anything to bring about a
world of absolute Justice sakazuki is
even willing to talk back to the five
Elders when they get in the way of his
vision which is pretty impressive even
the powerful Blackbeard decides to run
away from the magma Admiral stating that
he's not ready for that battle yet even
though he has whitebeards devil fruit at
this point and some of the world's worst
criminals on his crew I bet Blackbeard
would feel much more comfortable taking
him on now that he has KZ on on the crew
sakazuki possesses the magum magu noi
aka the magmag fruit this loia devil
fruit lets him create manipulate and
become magma sakazuki devil fruit
appeared to be of a higher order than
Aces initially it's been said that
because of Magma's unique properties and
its higher temperature sakazuki attack
injures Ace despite his loia defenses at
the same time in a previous video it was
common Ed that fire can actually reach a
higher temperature than magma even if
magma is hotter than your average fire
this raises the exciting potential of
Sabo being able to bring out more of the
flame fruits potential and get revenge
for Ace although honestly for me it's
hard to see such a big opponent being
beaten by Sabo especially after he
scarred Luffy and has so much history
with Luffy I've also read theories that
magma absorbs fire and that's why
sakazuki could get through Ace's
defenses or he just used hoaky but let
me know your favorite inter
interpretation in the comments anyways
the magma Admiral's loia powers are so
strong that he was able to permanently
change the climate of punk Hazard he can
use Armament hockey and observation
hockey and in fact all Marines ranked
vice admiral and up can use hockey it
has not been confirmed that sakazuki has
conqueror hockey but I'd be surprised if
he doesn't given his power and important
leader status in fact Odo was the first
to Hype up sakazuki he said before that
sakazuki is so strong that he could end
the one piece series within a year if he
were the protagonist and he said that
back in 2012 given the recent importance
placed on hockey and especially on
conqueror's hockey and how it's way more
important than fruit Powers it seems
pretty obvious that sakazuki has it to
me all in all this dude is definitely a
worthy antagonist for Luffy given his
power and history with our protagonist
and since gear five Luffy was able to
use Advanced hockey to punch magma kaido
without making physical contact and thus
without melting his arm he might be
ready to take on the Red Dog too let me
know what you think below is Luffy ready
to take on the current Fleet Admiral for
number two let's look at the currently
49-year-old Kuan aka aliji before Kuan
gave up being an admiral he went by
aliji which means blue pheasant after he
lost his fight against sakazuki Kuan
left the Marines and joined Blackbeard
of all people becoming the Titanic
captain of the 10th ship this was a very
curious turn on the one hand it makes
Blackbeard who was already presented as
being a forc to be reckoned with seem
even stronger on the other hand Kuan
could be a spy it is weird that sakazuki
let him survive their battle and didn't
seem that bothered when nudes of him
helping Blackbeard spread so it could be
that they set it up so that Kuan would
help the Marines by keeping a close eye
on Blackbeard we'll see what ends up
happening but it definitely seems
strange that the sangoku recommended
Kuan would join forces with Blackbeard
especially since Kuan seemed like the
nicest guy out of the three former
Admirals Kuan for his part is 9'9 in
tall so he's a bit shorter than sakazuki
and he's way more laidback than the
current Fleet Admiral practicing in his
own form of lazy Justice rather than
absolute Justice however more accurately
he has his own moral compass unlike
sakazuki he's compassionate at times
he's willing to help a child Robin
escape a buster call and he is willing
to not arrest the young Luffy after he
helps people by defeating crocodile
unlike sakazuki Kuan wouldn't want to
sacrifice a number of innocent lives
just to get rid of one potentially
guilty person Kuan is no doubt very
powerful otherwise sokku would not have
recommended him for Fleet Admiral and he
would not have lasted 10 days fighting
against the extremely powerful sakazuki
when a fight drags off for that long you
start to think that it may have gone
either way if conditions were only
slightly different sakazuki is even 6
years older so it's at least possible
that Kuan could become stronger it's
also noteworthy that most marine troops
preferred Kuan and supported him showing
that Kuan is a good leader who has the
ability to positively influence others
this ability to lead also hints at the
fact that he could be a conqueror hockey
user as well he's powerful enough to to
easily scare off someone as powerful as
doflamingo he was able to battle with
Whitebeard until Diamond josu one of
whitebeard's commanders entered the fry
allowing Whitebeard to move on Kuan took
advantage of a distraction and
eventually took joosu down without much
trouble my point is he can clearly fight
with the best of them and we're about to
see how true that is more recently we
saw how he joined Blackbeard after they
bonded over drinks at this point he was
at Rock Bottom having lost his leg and
career to sakazuki and then Blackbeard
offered him a position although Kuan
said he didn't trust them Blackbeard
pointed out that they don't have to be
best friends they are pirates which just
means they need aligned interests and as
a free man Kuan agreed to join him then
we saw him help defeat the legend
himself Marine hero GARP who is also his
mentor it even appeared that he ended
him by impaling him with ice yes GARP
was past his prime but the fact that
Kuan helped defeat Marine hero GARP
while Captain Blackbeard and other key
members were away makes the Blackbeard
pirates look very famili itable indeed
GARP through his actions helped Kobe and
the others escape but since Kobe is a
member of sword and thus not even an
official Marine now this has to look
like a big Blackbeard win and like a big
Marine loss especially since GARP like
each admiral has a whopping three
billion Berry Bounty given out by cross
Guild now let's look at kuan's D through
Powers more closely he ate the ice ice
fruit this loia fruit lets him create
manipulate and become ice he can easily
free fre miles of ocean and even giant
tsunamis he can freeze his enemies and
then easily shatter their bodies guan's
loia powers like sakazuki are strong
enough to permanently change the climate
of an area as we saw with Punk Hazard
what's especially cool about kuon punon
intended is that he can avoid the most
common threat of delu users by freezing
the sea water below him thus if he's
ever in a position where he's about to
fall in and drown he can just freeze the
water he regularly uses his freezing
powers to travel across the sea and the
fact that he just B bikes Over the Sea
makes him all the more awesome not to
mention hilarious what is perhaps the
most impressive thing about kuan's power
is how he is able to survive some hockey
imbued attacks like they were nothing
for instance when Whitebeard stabbed
through him with his hockey imbued
weapon kuza was able to come out of it
fine that's a whole other level of loia
Mastery right there it appears like Kuan
was able to make a hole in his body
before the weapon penetrated him and
thus avoided the damage obviously this
wouldn't work as well when he's being
punched with hockey infused fists as
happened during his fight against GARP
he clearly took damage during this fight
but it must be said he didn't take
significant damage he was even still
standing by the end of it while GARP lay
on the ground and impressive feat even
if he did have help like when invisible
shiryu stabbed GARP Kuan also possesses
observation hockey and Armament hockey
and if my rational speculation about
sakazuki is correct it's almost certain
that Kuan who fought him for 10 days and
now beat GARP is also an unconfirmed
conquer hockey user honestly considering
how many characters have conqueror
hockey including kid who just got
one-shotted by Shanks it wouldn't even
be that surprising if all Admirals have
conquer his hocky at this point hockey
aside Kuan can form sharp weapons out of
his ice and use them to attack his
opponents just look at how he finished
off GARP with a giant Spike of ice all
in all Kuan is more than a force to be
reckoned with and he's already proven to
be an insane addition to the Blackbeard
crew I mean think about it now
Blackbeard has a guy that was strong
enough to be Fleet at Admiral and a guy
who fought sakazuki for 10 days working
under him it's insane to think about but
let me know if you think he is truly a
Blackbeard Pirate or if you think he's
undercover in which case perhaps the
spike that appeared to finish GARP off
might have actually been a way to stop
the bleeding that shu's attack started
we know characters can be Frozen and
unfrozen later so it's possible but
personally I'd like to think that Kuan
is truly a Blackbeard Pirate and not a
double agent and hear me out it's
because it will make for a much more
more epic final clash between the straw
hats and the Blackbeard Pirates not to
mention it would be kind of predictable
if he was a member of sword and remember
if you're thinking Kuan is too good of a
guy to be working with Blackbeard
Whitebeard also worked for zebic the
fact is like Blackbeard said if their
interests align it might not matter that
their morals don't next let's look at
Luffy's latest opponent the current
58-year-old borino AKA kizaru his
Admiral Alias means yellow monkey the
usually gring kizaru is the only
remaining Admiral from the pre-time
skipped Trio since sakazuki was promoted
to Fleet Admiral and Kuan resigned Kizer
is also tall at 9t 11 in these three
Admirals towered over most people in
height and strength in the pre-time skip
one piece even if they feel less
Untouchable these days velino is the
oldest and that's definitely also
reflected by the wrinkles on his face
his form of justice is explained by Oda
as unclear Justice he's not as moral as
Kuan has been at times but he's also not
as much of an EXT extremist as sakazuki
and wouldn't take as much initiative
kizaru prefers to follow orders rather
than lead so he may well be the only one
out of the three without conqueror's
hockey since that clearly doesn't sound
like conqueror energy but again you got
Zoro with conqueror's hockey following
Luffy so in the end who knows kizaru
isn't a coldblooded machine and recently
we've seen that he wanted to avoid
hurting his former student sentomaru if
possible not to mention Bonnie he really
wanted stomato to just not get in the
way of his mission but even if he
doesn't want to hurt certain people
there is something that always makes him
prioritize the mission and his orders
and ultimately he will choose to follow
orders even if it means taking out
people like sentomaru or Bonnie who we
now know is only 12 years old I'm hoping
that soon we'll see what is this thing
whether a revealing formative flashback
or something else that makes him always
prioritize following orders over
following his feelings in regards to
combat he's among the best he's
extremely fast his loia fruit lets him
attack and move at the speed speed of
light he clashed against Legends like
silver Ry and Whitebeard and came out
fine he also attacked Luffy after
shank's first mate Ben Beckman
threatened him and even offered to go to
wano when he found out that big mom and
kaido formed an alliance think about how
crazy that is for a second kaidu and big
mom were the two living yonko with the
highest bounties together they had a
bounty around 9 billion berries to put
that in perspective the pirate king gold
D Roger had a bounty of around 5 A2
billion berries and kizu offers to go to
Wana even sakazuki is like chill bro so
it's quite clear that kizaru is not only
extremely strong but practically
Fearless most recently we saw him face
off against gear five Yono Luffy who is
coming off of a win against the
so-called strongest creature in the
world kaido and finally we've seen
kizaru and Admiral hit a ceiling against
Luffy to be fair kizaru did better than
I expected and it definitely puts the
Admirals in a more positive light
strengthwise before at least I think the
phandom felt like Yono level is above
Admiral level such te are problematic
because there is such variation in
yono's strength levels and even in
Admiral strength levels but there really
was that sense at least until buggy
became a yonko but when we see someone
like kizaru push gear five Luffy to the
point where Luffy is temporarily out of
commission even though Luffy was strong
enough to beat kaido it really makes the
Admirals look good Especially since one
would assume that sakazuki and the one
who challenged him kuon are even
stronger still it must be said Luffy was
too strong for kizaru to plow through
and he kept running away and trying to
complete his mission while Luffy kept
catching up then Luffy's star gun attack
causes kizu to see stars yes Luffy
reaches his gear five limit but when
asked about his rather sluggish work by
Elder Saturn Kizer replies I'm sorry I
failed you and I don't think I'll be
mobile anytime soon end quote the way I
read this fight is that gear five Luffy
outclasses kizaru but the problem is the
time limit of this draining form and
keep in mind against kaido he used the
form twice where here he only used it
once so far leading us to believe that
if he really needed to he could pull off
another gear five transformation so all
in all Luffy has gotten to the insane
point where he Cann out class Samano and
even an admiral but Oda did a good job
of making the once Untouchable seeming
kizaru put up an impressive show against
Luffy Ness kizaru's character definitely
deserves that respect however if the
elders are stronger than the Admirals as
most of us assume then it's clear that
Luffy is far from done and he will
continue to widen the gap between
himself and someone like kizaru this Arc
now let's briefly run through kizaru's
devil fruit power the pika pika no me
aka the glint glint fruit it allows
kizaru to create control and become
light he can shoot laser beams create
lightsabers to fight with and turn parts
of his body into light and then hit his
opponents with the force of light speed
not only can he travel at the speed of
light he can also use mirrors or
reflective surfaces to propel him so
that he can get to any point he wishes
to almost instantaneously as if you were
teleporting this makes it all the more
impressive that Luffy could catch up to
him and take him out of of commission I
assume that if kizaru wasn't so fast and
good at running away Luffy wouldn't have
had so much trouble with him kizaru is
also skilled at using observation hockey
and Armament hockey if I had to pick
someone who's least likely to have
conquer his hockey out of the first
three Admirals as mentioned it's kizaru
but still like I said I wouldn't be
surprised if all Admirals had
conqueror's hockey before we jump to the
new Admirals let's look at the now
79-year-old sokku the Buddha before he
was Fleet Admiral he too was an admiral
he's one of the legendary ogs along with
GARP Whitebeard Goldie Roger Captain
rocks and so on sangoku was one of the
Marines that pyate King Goldie Roger
respected the most the other being GARP
and with GARP sangoku even defeated
Shiki the Golden Lion one of rogers's
greatest pirate Rivals at the Battle of
marine Ford he is able to restrain GARP
and send all of the skilled Blackbeard
Pirates flying backwards with one of his
attacks he's no longer in his prime but
he's clearly still one of the strongest
characters in the series he possesses
the hito hito noi model dutu AKA the
human human fruit model Buddha now I
assume I don't have to tell you that
this is a mythical Zone fruit a class
rarer than even loia type fruits this
fruit allows its user to transform into
a large Golden Buddha his strength is
magnified in this form giving his blows
immense destructive power he can also
release powerful shock waves in this
form I would assume that he has to have
one of the best non- hockey related
defenses when he's transformed soku
unlike the other skilled Admirals on
this list is confirmed to be able to use
all three types of hockey including the
rare conqueror's hockey next let's look
at Admiral Zephyr the non-canon Admiral
from One Piece Film Z and if you haven't
checked this movie out I highly
recommend it it's my favorite of the one
piece movies Z AKA black arm Zephyr was
a former Marine Admiral and even
instructor who trained sakazuki Kuan and
kizaru if you can believe it he was an
admiral during Roger and Prime
whitebeard's Time hyping him up even
more he didn't rely on a devil fruit but
rather on his impressive hockey Mastery
as his nickname black arm Zephyr alludes
to he clearly wasn't at his prime during
the events of the movie since he was 74
years old his mechanical arm the battle
Smasher as it's called is unique and
pretty cool The Story Goes he lost his
arm when it was cut off by an unknown
pirate with a devil fruit power almost
his entire division was massacred all
but two of them when this same pirate
was invited to become a warlord it was
the final straw and Zephyr renounced the
Marines and started the Neo Marines it's
a very cool idea because we know how
corrupt the Marines are and this guy
who'd seen that firsthand decided to put
a stop to it and started a new Marines
organization a very interesting
backstory for an antagonist as you can
imagine he replaced his missing arm with
the mechanical arm and a potential
weakness became a strength the arm is
embedded with sea Stone making it very
effective against devil fruit users
including loia users like kizaru throw a
machine gun and a destructive cannon in
it and you have a very sweet all-around
weapon ultimately a Gear 2 Luffy weakens
him and and a Bas level Luffy defeats
him so you can bet he won't be anywhere
near the top of a strongest Admiral's
list especially at this age but he's a
great character nonetheless and helps
make one Piece Film Z one of if not the
best one piece movies if you have one
one piece movie that you like even more
let me know what it is in the comments
next we have one of the new Admirals the
54-year-old fujit to which means was
steria Tiger he's one of the shorter
Admirals at 8' 10 in tall like who on
fujit to is against the extremist view
of absolute Justice as opposed to
sakazuki who is willing to sacrifice the
innocent fujit Tor prioritized as
protecting people he is blind and says
that he earned his lack of sight by his
own actions and that he shut his eyelids
on his own after he saw too many things
he didn't care for however after
encounter with Luffy fujit to supposes
that he shouldn't have closed his eyes
because he wants to take a look at
Luffy's face to see how such an honest
guy looks in front of the entire world
fujitora apologized to proper king of
dress Rosa Riku after doflamingo is
defeated and and says that it was
through the actions of pirates
Gladiators and citizens that the country
seized Victory this is practically
sakazuki worst nightmare and fujitora
even chooses not to apologize to him
after doing it fujitora an admiral
admits in the open that the Marines can
do the wrong thing and make mistakes
while Pirates can do the right thing and
protect the innocent you can't help but
like the guy who's willing to follow his
own moral compass no matter what his
Superior the fleet Admiral will think
fujitora is strong enough to easily
block attacks from former warlord
doflamingo and dress Ros alffy couldn't
do much to him either except leave a
positive impression he could also clash
with Sabo the number two ranked member
of the revolutionaries and an extremely
skilled fighter in his own right for an
extended period of time without taking
any significant damage now let's get
into fujitora's devil fruit the paramia
type Zushi Zushi noi this fruit gives
him gravity powers that he uses in
conjunction with his sword he can create
gravitational forces that move
horizontally or vertically he can use
downward gravity to trap an opponent in
place or he can use gravitational force
to repel people and things away from
himself my favorite though is that he
can even pull down meteorites from space
madra style even someone as skilled and
experienced as do Flamingo couldn't
believe that this dude was bringing
actual meteorite down to the Earth
fujitora is also skilled at observation
Armament hockey he's been seen imbu his
sword with hockey as well his
observation hockey is what lets him
fight effectively without vision and it
almost seems like it more than
compensates for his lack of vision
because he's so good with observation
hockey that he can sense people's
emotions and thoughts not just their
fast physical movements and the other
new Admiral we have to cover is aramaki
his Alias means greenbull this is the
Admiral We Knew by far the least about
when I made my previous versions of this
video we had seen his silhouette smiling
and joking around with fujitora even
while sakazuki was mad at the ladder we
knew greenbull had long wavy hair and
wore a marine coat we also knew that he
hadn't had a bite to eat for three years
but he did reveal his love of pretty
ladies we knew that he was strong enough
to clash along with fellow Admiral fujit
Tor with the formidable captains of the
Revolutionary Army no small feet
especially for a man running on an empty
stomach the flamingo had also said that
there were rumors that both of the new
Admirals were powerful monsters as with
all the other Admirals he knows
observation armor and hockey in previous
versions of this video I hyped up
Greenbow because Oda kept him for last
shout in mystery which is usually what
Shonen authors do for the stronger
characters but green Bull's first
introduction as a fighter sort of ended
anticlimactically more specifically as
well see his hype was sort of sacrificed
to Hype up Shanks even more there were
lots of theories floating around about
greenbull before including that he had a
plant-based fruit power and that he was
actually zoro's father one of these
theories has already pretty much been
confirmed the reason I thought he might
have plant-based Powers was because of
the Green in his name and also the fact
that he didn't eat which suggested to me
that he might get his nutrients through
other means like maybe photosynthesis
when he finally appeared in chapter 1052
it looked good for this Theory since he
was seen flying around with a kind of
flower helicopter sticking out from his
back got a hand it to the Admirals they
definitely have unique and fun ways of
traveling at this point sakazuki is
asking him where is he through his snail
phone and green bull says in the air as
if that helps narrow it down it's
moments like this that seem to support
the idea of him being zoro's father
since Zoro is legendary for his lack of
Direction sense anyways greenball
finally spots wano ahead and sakazuki
tells him don't you dare make things any
worse and greenbull simply says I know I
know gez then we head to chapter 1053
where we see his power face and fruit
abilities at work although his powers
are plant related his nutrient gaining
process which allows him to not eat is
much more deadly than photosynthesis we
see him launching Roots all over the
place that penetrate the former Beast
Pirates and he sucks nutrients from them
in that way in turn the victims begin to
look dried up and old so I guess if
fujitora is similar to mad with his
meteor dropping Powers greenbull is sort
of similar to hashirama with his wood
style Powers the craziest part is that
even king and queen two Yono commanders
with bounties of 1.32 billion and 1.39
billion respectively are easily dealt
with now yes they were hurt during the
fight and King is even shown with
bandages not to mention their loss of
morale after losing the war but still
it's been a week and Luffy and Zoro seem
fine so it still seems impressive
furthermore despite the fact that they
were the strongest commanders of the
so-called strongest creature in the
world in the Yono with the highest
Bounty greenbull comment that a guy in
his position can't go around getting
beaten by pirate subordinates thus even
if they were in tiptop shape the
implication is that greenbull would
still crush them and it's a big deal
because we saw how Ben Beckman spoke
with Admiral kizaru at the Paramount War
and the respect kizaru seemed to give
him he commanded him at gunpoint not to
do anything and at first at least kizaru
put his hands up and said oops you're
Ben Beckman end quote clearly showing a
lot more respect to the Yono Commander
than green bull showed queen and king
yes it's likely in part because Ben
Beckman is stronger than king and queen
but it's still no worthy this is an
interesting moment because greenbull
with his actions and words suggests that
most of the time Admirals are stronger
than Yono commanders perhaps not a
shocking Revelation but interesting
nonetheless and it makes sense since if
there are usually three Admirals at a
time while there are four yonko it would
be weird for the Admirals to be
struggling with every yonko Commander
that being said it does appear like
Marco and especially Ben Beckman stand
out as being pretty special and I'm sure
Zoro will join that club as well we will
get into the specifics but right now let
me know in the comments where you would
rank greenbull in power compared to the
other Admirals we've seen like kizaru
fujitora and so on I'd love to see how
you guys rank the Admirals after these
latest chapters from weakest to
strongest but back to the story and we
even see greenbull drinking beer through
his roots another potential clue to him
being zoro's father after sakazuki told
him to not cause any more trouble he
does the complete opposite and calls for
a battleship to be sent to him and even
tells the listener to not squeal to
sakazuki he says he loves sakazuki cut
no cornner attitude and he wants to hear
sakazuki Praise when greenbull brings
him Luffy's head so just the fact that
he thinks he can take down everyone that
just brought down kaido and big mom also
speaks volumes about his confidence and
potential strength then against the
Defenders of wano the red scabbers M
Yamato we see him use his Mor Mor noi
AKA Woods Woods loia fruit Powers these
powers make him a forest human allowing
him to create control and even transform
into Flora in his own words the forest
is just as much the Cradle of life as
the sea it is pure loia nature itself
and that use of the word pure loia makes
me wonder if this is a special category
even among loas just like mythical zone
is a special category among zones but
anyways all of this is very hype as is
seeing him combine with the nature
around him using the Earth like an
organic Mecca he can make giant arms pop
out of it and use them to attack his
opponents still we can't say the result
we saw was that impressive he cries Yao
that's some tough hockey when Yamato
hits his head he then traps Momo's
Dragon form with roots pretty
effortlessly Riso uses fire and if you
know your Pokemon you know that's super
effective against a grass type it looks
like it works at first but then adamaki
makes it clear he's only playing around
saying and I quote you think I could
hack it as an admiral if I was actually
susceptible to such an obvious weakness
end quote his root stabs Riso and he
absorbs the nutrients out of him until
key too looks withered and aged it's
clear that the scabbards are having a
lot of trouble as is pointed out for
every route they cut another grows
before long green bull seems to have
them all trapped in his roots desperate
Momo launches a blast breath and another
until green bull has to grow back from
something the size of a tiny Clover he's
finally about to get serious from the
looks of it before he senses Shanks as
hockey to put things simply it freaks
him out he puts his hands up as if in
surrender and says look I'm not picking
a fight with you guys end quote and and
just leaves sure he wasn't defeated by
Momo Yamato and the scabbards but he
didn't make quick work of them either
then Shanks is hockey alone scares him
off before he can even pass the
scabbards and get to Luffy compare that
to how formidable kizaru Kuan and
sakazuki felt in the beginning of
onepiece and you can only say that
greenbull has been underwhelming for an
admiral so far I'll give him the benefit
of the doubt though that he has much
more up his floral sleeves than we've
seen so far also worth mentioning is
that adamaki like the other Admirals and
GARP has a current cross skilled Bounty
of three crowns or three billion berries
so like Luffy's current Yono Bounty and
again like all Admirals greenbull is an
observation Armament hockey user lastly
I got to mention the eighth Admiral Kong
who doesn't usually make it in these
Admiral lists but should when you think
about it the dude is currently the world
government commander-in-chief but before
that he was the fleet Admiral and like
Fleet Admiral sokin sakazuki he was most
likely an ordinary Admiral before that
but even if he was somehow an exception
to the got to get promoted from Admiral
to Fleet Admiral rule he deserves to be
on this list since Fleet Admiral is just
a higher ranking Admiral than a normal
Admiral and yes I probably overuse the
word Admiral in that sentence but moving
on Kong is also the guy who kept trying
to promote GARP to Admiral during Rogers
era only for garb to turn him down
repeatedly we know he has to have Master
over observation Armament hockey but
chances are he has conquers hocky as
well although we never saw him in action
we know that all Fleet Admirals have
been very strong and the guy who was
Fleet Admiral during Rogers time is
surely not an exception to that rule
then throwing the fact that he had prime
GARP and sokku working under him and
that in this series where the strongest
family is called monkey this dude is
called Kong a reference to exceptionally
strong monkeys like King Kong and Donkey
Kong you know this guy has to be a
monster he is now the highest government
Authority besides the five elders and
emu hopefully we'll learn more about him
moving forward and I can update this
section in a future video because
currently we know the least about Kong's
Powers now we have to admit that the
Admirals were hype but the Yono are even
more hype so you definitely don't want
to miss my updated all seven Yono in
their powers explained video link on
screen right now like And subscribe to
help us reach 2 million subscribers here
on YouTube and I'll see you in the next
one